she said I felt that acquiescing to a
false claim compromised my Integrity I'm
pleased with the outcome and I felt a
quivering in my place when they read it
was so Preposterous I had to quit about
my glitter goop out of my budget
okay you guys hear about Gwyneth Paltrow
getting rammed into yep yeah
a little bit I don't know anything this
is a while ago though she got this is
seven years ago yeah I believe it was
more than seven years ago but someone
crashed into her at a at a ski resort
this guy named Terry Sanderson he's a
retired optometrist well he couldn't
even see
because he's retired love it got him um
so Gwyneth Paltrow is skiing this guy
Terry Sanderson is skiing he crashes
into her but he claims she crashes into
him during their ski trip she said she
said and he's like I'm suing Gwyneth
paltrows for 300 Grand and damages for
the injuries I sustained no no he was no
he was trying to see for 3.1 million and
then the judge said at most you can only
get 300 Grand thank you Anthony you're
welcome are you gonna Sue pepper pops
man so he files a lawsuit seeking 300K
and damages
after she allegedly plowed into him but
then she's like I'm counter suing your
ass for one dollar and legal fees
because you you're to blame for for the
collision and you know it and he
basically
um
you know lost he just lost so he has to
pay the dollar and legal fees it's full
of [__] [__] or what he sounds like
someone who's trying to exploit someone
you know how many times I [__]
crashed on the slopes it's just part of
the thing yeah I didn't know you could
even sue somebody for that I didn't know
either that's kind of wild it just
happened you got beginners you got
people you don't see it just it just did
he get like super injured in the crash
or something
um yes and he's well he claims that he
like had permanent damages from this uh
but he doesn't have any visible like arm
missing did he come up to court with a
neck brace
so like he crashed or like there's a
crash and he gets [__] up like
permanent damage nothing happened to her
physically no she was fine she was
sitting with a coffee mug was a straight
lying he's trying to bust a [__] car
insurance fraud so that's the thing that
oh Gwyneth Paltrow's attorney kind of
sees on that he was grilling
um Mr Sanderson about the severity of
the injuries questioning him about all
the trips and activities that he did to
social media after the so-called hit him
yeah dude it was pretty um damn they got
him the jury basically all agreed pretty
easily according to one of the jurors
who spoke out she was an Iron Man yeah
she was an Iron Man she's Pepper Pot so
Pepper Pot pepper pots man pots
um but but they were basically the jury
was confused because they're like he
hurt her and now he wants money from her
because she's going to Paltrow yeah he's
like he thought he could get a little
payday [__] how you want to suck a
chick in the [__] can you counter sue
for being a con sounds like a good deal
like can they just show you because
you're just being a comment and then
call them out on it yeah I think like
Ryan said it's possible it's like you
wasted my time I lost all this money
yeah and on top of that like yeah you
were just trying to finesse me that's
what she just won is the counter suit
because she's oh but she got a dollar
but her legal fees probably cost more
than his oh you know it bro so all her
lawyers are happy yeah yeah but also the
lawyers were re did you guys see any of
the Court footage the lawyers both
seemed like idiots on their on both
sides on both sides really they were
both super non-articulate couldn't even
really describe [__] it was so weird by
the way and you know it's kind of a
crazy thing and this is [__] up of me
because I'm cynical I'm very cynical
person not my best quality but Gwyneth
Paltrow turned it on on the stand and
maybe she's truthful maybe not but I see
an actress and she was talking about how
when it initially happened the guy like
skied into her and she thought it was a
sexual assault for a second and I'm like
oh [__] did he have a boner because he
had a boner that's what she said yeah
yeah because he was going downhill with
a hard and he had like like four and
four inches of padding but she still
felt the boner oh because he was like
when he crashed he thrust yeah yeah yeah
because you know like when you when you
have when you go down and you ski right
you have these right yeah so when he
went up to her he's pushed he's exactly
like that and that's what her lawyer was
saying and that was the diet of the
lawyer stood up and did that a couple
times and he said oops yep yeah he said
goops yeah the footage of the lawyer
trying to explain the situation it's
super hard to visualize because he's
just like and then went under and hit
the you're just watching it for like
forever you're like what the [__]
going on that's why I wish he would just
go he's like so miss potro's is like
obviously bent over position my client
was not anticipating that you know what
I don't really know where I'm going with
this can you just please give this man
some money you have a lot of [__]
money a lot of [__] money even the
dude's lawyer was like when Gwyneth
Paltrow's on the stand he's like or she
was it's a woman and she was like uh
would you say that you're friends with
Taylor Swift and then Paul was all I
know I would say we're like good friends
I've maybe been to her show a couple
times she's like so you wouldn't say
you're good friends and they're like
objection relevance
maybe it was a personal question because
she's a fad but she just wanted to know
so like what's she like what's Taylor
Swift like apparently like the the
object of her even like asking that was
supposedly because Taylor Swift did the
same one dollar counter shoot on
somebody so she may have thought that
like oh you're doing this because you
someone's Court techniques you're
getting legal advice from Taylor Swift
that sounds so [__] dumb why are you
asking and then uh well even if she did
or did it like the judge was even like
so what is the relevance and that
lawyer's like well because she said she
wasn't friends with her so I don't know
I'm asking like what the [__] is this
that's a lawyer Kangaroo Court
yeah so one of the things about this
that has emerged as well is Gwyneth
Paltrow goes up to the guy after she
wins and she puts her hand on her
shoulder and she says I wish you well
and then he said thank you like sweetie
or whatever basically that's funny
because I would have pictured if she
touched him he would go ah yeah
Susan Souza for that while we're here
another one like a soccer penalty yeah
that's great that's so whack yeah um
this was a [__] [__] yeah dude
I guess optometrists who retire kind of
soft huh well they don't have a lot put
away they feel like a [__] because no
one ever calls them a real doctor they
just went down under dentists now oh
[__] and then obviously the Bedrock for
dentists is chiropractors is holding it
all up
the Bedrock yeah
it's growing up you know it's going up
since like uh on the social media it's
tick tock all the social yeah all the
tick tocks all the asmrs oh yeah it's
just it just works for them you know
what I mean the ASM sort of the
thumbnail it is fun to watch I've had a
car yeah and they're always big busted
girls too spotted busty chicks their
credibility is I'm just saying it's
going up there and if optometrists had
that kind of technique
[__] up eyes giant giant breasted eyes
these chicks they bring they wear yoga
pants that the guy sticks like a [__]
vacuum into and they suck even more air
out of it yeah there's like those vacuum
packed foodsavers this is insane dude
like there's no air in those chicks like
between their legs and their [__]
let's see it's crazy how do you find
yoga pants where it also goes in when
you have a butt crease which I'm telling
you that's like a style they designed
them well they dip them in water too
it's like it's paper mache dude that's a
pretty crazy design I love yoga pants
I love yoga me too hey airports before
yoga pants and after yoga pants right
way better way better now way better but
I don't like yoga pants I don't like it
I like that we don't have a high
metallic but please explain your gayness
no it's not gay because I think they're
inappropriate please explain your
gayness I like the bra free movement I
love the bra Freeman yeah I love the
beaker movement
oh goop though huh
we're about this is your favorite
clothing brand that is the flexo right
it's like if you're gonna counter Sue
and be like all you have to do is pay
for legal fees and one dollar yeah
that's it's like that's like a Price is
Right Move yeah it's like not only am I
gonna [__] destroy you but I don't
even need your money you're just wasting
my time so I'm just gonna like show
everybody how what's crazy is how
stubborn he is too because like it takes
a lot to get to court yeah like there's
so much conversation back and forth like
have you ever worked a lawyer like
there's so much verbal stuff and once
you can't handle it because even all
lawyers will tell you like a lot of shut
down deals yeah let's talk it out before
anything gets to paper so I'm sure he's
heard a million times from her lawyer do
you really want to sue where the
password do you really want to sue my
client so it has so much before it
officially becomes paperwork so he had
so many outs and he didn't want any of
it that's the sucky thing about like
when you have a lawyer you can never
tell if your lawyer is robbing you too
yeah yeah because a lot of people a lot
of people's lawyers are like that
they're like hey we can Witness we can
get this money but it's like win or lose
you're like a broker you make money on
the deal no matter how it goes yeah
because then you work with the lawyer
and then the lawyer goes okay here's
like this is like my uh what is the
theme my hourly where you decide to like
work with them a settlement no no you
and the lawyer like he's like like
you're they're representing you now yeah
so you get the sheet and you're like
well [__] now I need another lawyer to
look over the sheet that this guy's
supposed to protect me it's like what
the [__] right it's endless yeah yeah
there's been there's been times where I
remember like when uh when Foo is being
sued by Rick Ross's team it was almost
like the lawyers on both sides had this
not of agreement to like make this last
forever oh so they would just get paid
even though they knew that that under
parity Clause saying every day I'm
shuffling as a parody of every damn
hustling was totally fine whoa he got
they got sued for that yeah but he was
being sued for that but even though we
everybody knew that like oh there's no
way that's gonna he'll never win that
because it's fine to do that but still
both sides were like well let's keep it
going keep it rolling these dudes were
paid for like 10 years can't you just be
like
I'll call you later
and and not kind of answer the phone oh
that's a good way that's really good Joe
yeah it's a stalling technique because I
mean Warriors
so Gwyneth Paltrow who is known for odd
statements at times right
um she didn't speak with reporters out
the trial but they released a statement
via her attorneys she said I felt that
acquiescing to a false claim compromise
my Integrity I'm pleased with the
outcome and I felt a quivering in my
[__] when they read
and he goes it was so Preposterous I had
a queef out my [__] glitter goop I
vagina that'd be sick if he gave her a
one like on the spot yeah damn you God
and it's a crusty dollar too you should
have to pay her on the spot yeah he
should have to pay on the spot what if
his petty ass pulls out a hundred
pennies
these are the questions that should be
asked in court
dude have you tried to count 100 pennies
it's so annoying just a hundred though
she should it's been a few decades
except trying to count 100 pennies
thank you